哈囉大家好
我是柯編
今天已經初四了
然後距離上班的時間真的是非常近
你有沒有覺得時間過很快啊
9編：沒有
其實很多人就是年後之後
會收到非常大量的郵件
既然Gemini都已經導入在
Gmail信箱裡面了
我就在想
Gemini是不是可以幫我處理
以下這四種情境呢
第一個情境是
每個人都適用所有信件的摘要
幫我摘要整個過年期間所有的信件
然後幫我判斷說
在上班的第一天優先要處理的事情
第二個是人資適用
像人資他可能會收到大量類似的信件
我希望他可以幫我做橫向的比較
履歷投進來我的信箱裡面
然後在同一個職位
我要怎樣快速的篩選
適合來面試的人
第三個情境是
採購適用
Gemini到底有沒有辦法幫我在信箱裡面
讀取PDF、JPG跟Word或Excel檔
然後來幫我做出報價單的比較
第四個是客服適用
他可不可以幫我判斷出這些信件
有哪些
情緒比較不穩定的客戶
需要急迫的回覆
然後並且幫我擬出一個
很完整的客服信件回覆給他
相信這四種情境
也是很多人會需要用到的
先說這個功能目前是只有購買
Gemini的人才可以使用
那我目前是使用企業版的Google Workspace
現在就馬上來幫你測試
9編：好的
第一種情境
其實我一開始使用的時候
簡單的在Gemini旁邊的這個欄位搜尋
摘要今天的所有信件
有沒有出來了
他很快的就跑出來一個結果
幫我統計所有的報價單
比方說像音效的報價單
日文的報價單
然後剪輯費的報價單
相關的履歷
他會橫向的統整
我今天收到的相關的履歷
然後還有一封客訴信
是
有一個非常激動的客訴信
大概就這樣子
我一開始想說哇塞
但緊接著我就發現一個問題是
為什麼來源只有十封
今天早上收到的信件
其實應該有超過十封的信件
可是他在這裡居然只有幫我做十封
然後我就想說
是不是我的prompt下的不夠精準
所以我中間花了非常多時間在測試說
是不是我沒有定義好
所謂的所有信件到底是什麼
所以我重新下一次prompt給你們看
我的prompt下的是
請搜尋
2026年2月13日所有的Gmail信件
請務必讀取每一封郵件
接下來設定他回覆的摘要方式是
郵件的清單核對
分類的摘要
to do list
以及漏讀的
就是確認說他總共處理了幾封信件
然後確保沒有任何的遺漏
OK我們送出去看看
OK他這裡還是跟我講說
2026年的2月13日
所有的摘要信件總共處理了十封
並且沒有遺漏
但是實際上我今天收到的
我來算一下
上面搜尋的時間
我光是今天就是2月13號
我就收到了24封信
可是他在這邊的判讀
他只有判讀了十封信
懷疑是不是他可能跟中文比較不熟
所以我就下了
英文的prompt
其實跟剛剛中文版的prompt是一樣的
只不過我有特別下一個指令是告訴他說
最後給我的結果還是要用繁體中文
然後他跑出來了
比較詳細的
條列式的信件
但是總共幫我處理了九封信
並且在最後漏讀的檢查
他完全沒有作為
今天早上有請另外一個同事幫我測試說
他自己有購買Google One
然後這個東西是不是在Google One
一樣也會遇到一模一樣的問題
結果他遇到的問題是一樣的
但是我覺得他的優點還是
他可以大概幫你列出來
今天會遇到哪一些問題
有哪些信件是優先順序需要先去處理的
但是你實際上還是要花時間去
橫向的比對說是不是有漏掉信件
然後是不是有被他漏讀的內容
才可以快速的判斷說
是不是有哪些東西需要
緊急安排在今天要處理
下一個情境是人資適用
如果你是人資
你一定會遇到大量的應徵信件
如果老闆問你說請幫我篩選一下履歷
到底誰適合優先來面試
然後告訴我原因
過去你可能需要花很多時間
做交叉比對
首先你可能需要看完所有的信件
並且做表單
然後告訴老闆你判斷的理由到底是什麼
現在在Gemini
他有辦法幫你做到這件事情
就是我當初也覺得這東西一定做得出來
從剛剛的經驗就知道說
這個情境應該要把它
分為同一個職務
有沒有超過十封信件來作為判斷基準
超過十封信件的話
第一個步驟應該是你要逐一的
把所有的應徵履歷的信開起來
你就會去比對說
這個人到底是不是
你想要邀請來面試的人
如果不是的話
首先把這個人的信刪掉
你就可以把信件壓縮在十封信以內
再做橫向的比較
那現在示範一次給你們看
首先講一下我們這些都是
螢幕上看到的這些東西都是我們偽造履歷
裡面的內容呢
其實大部分都是簡單的摘要
可能會有告訴學歷啊什麼之類的
但是沒有PDF檔
所以他目前判讀的方向
還是以信件內的文字內容為主
所以我接下來給他的prompt是
請使用Gmail擴充功能
搜尋營編部所寄出來的信件
然後內容包含
泛科學院測試
就是這是我們的測試信
然後還有應徵的履歷
所有文件
然後請務必逐一讀取每位應徵者的內容
整理成以下的表格
然後表格內容我們就包含了
姓名年紀學歷
還有工作經歷等等的
我們送出試試看
有沒有出來了
9編：哇～
9編：剛剛都失敗
9編：現在有成功了一些
好你有沒有發現
他其實也只有讀九封信而已
9編：Oh no
真的超鬧的
超鬧的就是你看
9編：還是這個篩選九封
9編：也是天擇的一環
剩下其他人都不值得被篩選嗎
9編：這運氣也是實力的一部分
雖然有點蠢
但是你還是要看完每一封信之後
把信件濃縮到十封
然後接下來你再下那prompt的
他就會幫你做出來這個比較
如果你今天要寄給老闆的話
你就按插入告訴老闆說
這些人有沒有看到
他唯一快的點就是這個
你不用做表格
可以很快的就是寄給老闆說
我覺得這次有這麼多人來應徵
我覺得這幾個最OK
然後請老闆過目一下
第三個就是財務報價單的比較
因為有時候我們可能會收到
很多種不同格式的報價單
比方說有人可能會給你PDF
有些人可能會給你照片
然後也有可能是excel檔
或者是word檔
我們會好奇說
究竟他有沒有辦法幫我們橫向的做比較
這都是我們虛擬出來的報價單
所以我下給他的指令是
請搜尋我Gmail
2026年2月13號的標題
包含報價單的郵件
然後並讀取這信件中的PDF
JPG、Excel的內容
提取各家供應商的品名、單價
數量和總價
並且幫我整理成一個表格進行比價
最後分析哪一家最划算
好 結果出來了
Gemini跑出來一個限制聲明
他說我的工具無法讀取
和分析所有的類型
他說尤其是圖片檔JPG檔跟Excel檔
做詳細的表格數據來進行自動化的比較
只能成功的分析出一份PDF檔
所以大家可以看到
我們這兩封其實都是同一封信
他幫我整理出來說
這個人他報了兩次的價格
一個是中文翻譯一個是多少錢
也有列出來說
無法分析的信件到底是長怎樣
比方說提供的圖片是JPG檔
告訴我說這張圖片是JPG檔沒有辦法讀
然後這個是Excel
然後剪輯費也是Excel
然後有一個愛死寂寞工作室
它是Word檔
他也沒有辦法比較
他最後面就會列出來說
這幾封信來源是什麼
但是我同樣也要比較一下說
他是不是有完整的幫我抓到報價單
哼！
他還是有幫我漏掉報價單的部分
他只有幫我抓出日文帳單
9編：這也是物盡天擇的一環
很可能被Gemini篩選掉了呢
9編：為什麼廠商沒回我
9編：為什麼公司沒回我
9編：啊 物盡天擇
(無言的笑聲)
你還是要花時間再去做橫向的比較
也許有一些比較快的方式
中間的測試也讓我們知道說
PDF有可能是有效的
如果大家回去測試的時候
跟我遇到一樣的狀況
或者是你下的指令比我還要好
總之現在報價單這個有一些限制
這同時也告訴廠商
就不要再提供什麼JPG檔
因為說不定未來AI就會把你篩選掉
AI進步很快
有可能它接下來就可以讀了
這也很難說
最後一個情境
就是客服適用的情境
究竟Gemini有沒有辦法幫我篩選出
具有情緒性的信件
然後幫我做一個情緒的封鎖
如果你收到一封信
然後它滿滿的驚嘆號
然後罵很難聽的話
其實你身為客服也會覺得說
天啊情緒壓力好大
我這封信我不知道該怎麼回
那這時候Gemini就非常的好用
好我們一樣也是用我們公司營編部
寄來很多相關的客訴信
然後裡面內容也是好幾封
就是情緒非常不滿的
等級有
強烈不滿
網路維修進度緩慢
而且客服溝通效率極差
接下來還有一個
買東西被羞辱成這樣
我真的想去死啊
9編：買東西被羞辱成這樣！！
9編：我真的想去死啊！！！
很厲害而且他還超多驚歎號
下一秒再不處理的話
他可能就去自X
9編：那是不是也不用處理了
然後還有一個正式一點的
感覺就是法律人的
有理智的法律人寄的信
他說致貴公司的法務
總之他就用很文鄒鄒的字
然後告訴各位說
根據
依據什麼法什麼鬼之類的東西
他看起來比較理智
但是他也是
下一秒就要把你告上法院的狀態
好我們來看一下
他究竟會怎樣判斷
這些客訴信
那我給他下的 prompt 是
你是一位親切
而且有效率的客服專員
在 Gmail 找出最近七天
客戶情緒較為焦慮
以及提及產品問題的緊急信件
請針對每封信件提供客戶名稱
以及信件主旨
核心問題的簡述
擬一份專業且具有同理心的回覆草稿
待我確認後發送
好我們看他會跑怎樣
◢▆▅▄▃崩╰(〒皿〒)╯潰▃▄▅▇◣
他居然沒有跑出來
இдஇ
_(┐ ◟;ﾟдﾟ)ノ
我早上測試是有成功的
等一下我們看他寫什麼
這段指定期間內沒有找到
客戶情緒較為焦慮
以及提及產品問題
不行我要再測試一個
下一個 prompt 是
你是一位專業的客服專員
請搜尋 Gmail 中
2月9號到2月13號
需要待回覆的客訴信件
請列出摘要
指令沒有這麼複雜
因為我剛才還叫他擬回信
他的確有幫我跑出來這些
但是有沒有發現
他其實就只有跑那個
營編部出來的東西
9編：沒有發現
9編：他很棒了
9編：我鼓勵他
在畫外音的那個喬安
她有真實的寄一封
另外一封信進來
然後但是他沒有讀到
你看
那個去死的那封信
就沒有
沒有寄給我
9編：他可能判斷說他真的要死掉了( ˘•ω•˘ )
所以就不用修了嗎
是這樣嗎
9編：不知道 (´◉‿◉｀)
但是他還是有幫我
處理了幾封信
然後他們的狀況
大概是怎樣
回覆了一些建議給我
尤其是針對第一封
嚴重的法律聲明
所以他現在是
怕法律的人的概念
9編：他就應該是有自己的驕傲( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
9編：他覺得
9編：正式一點的回信
9編：他才會認為是重要的事情
我跟你講他早上不是這樣(|||ﾟдﾟ)
他早上優先選擇
那個要去死的信
9編：他是一個善變的雙子座(Gemini)
沒錯
善變的雙子座(ﾟ皿ﾟﾒ)
好吧
以上就是
我們今天四個案例的測試
嚴格來講我們
沒有一個成功
9編：原本的腳本是寫說
9編：嚴格來說只有第四種情境
9編：才有辦法實現
結果
＼(●o○;)ノ
不可以講髒話
結果反而是履歷的
好像
算成功吧
9編：算比較好
9編：需要大家去
9編：依照自己的情境
9編：去做不同的改變
9編：丟文件給他其實都能處理
9編：只是他自己去抓信件的時候
9編：沒那麼智慧
十封數量限制
我每天有一百封信
你只能讀十封
我幹嘛要你這個助理ヽ(`Д´)ノ
真的是氣死我了
9編：每個月費多少錢
9編：我們直接變慣老闆
對
還是要講一下
就是雖然這四種情境
今天可能都有某方面的缺點
你需要認知到
你的工作流程到底是什麼
拆解你的問題
分析說你想達到的目標
到底是什麼
不斷的修正你自己的指令
就像我們剛才看到的就是
各種失敗
但是你還是可以察覺到
他還是有慢慢的在進步
9編：明年的這時候
9編：說不定我們已經
9編：在履歷上面玩得風生水起
說不定接下來有一個
如何寫作才可以讓AI判讀
最快判讀自己的履歷
9編：有可能
就是要有一些關鍵字
一定要藏在最前面
9編：那我們下一集呢
9編：會是很多人類即將被取代的新聞
9編：如果有興趣的話
9編：歡迎大家一起關注我們的頻道
9編：留言
9編：留言啦
最後要講就是
AI大家好像很FOMO(錯失恐懼症)
但是
實際上剛才測試下來
其實它還沒有這麼厲害
加油
9編：你們還是有機會的
還是有機會
9編：你們不會被取代的
(╯✧∇✧)╯
新年快樂
拜拜
9編：結尾就是
9編：兩個社畜在那邊就是
｡ﾟヽ(ﾟ´Д`)ﾉﾟ｡
ヾ(;ﾟ;Д;ﾟ;)ﾉﾞ
大家趕緊下班
9編：我們才是那個工作做不好的人
(;´༎ຶД༎ຶ`)